turn the mat wall show over the
Thanksgiving holiday leftists invited us
to shamefully grovel and beg forgiveness
for the alleged atrocities committed by
our ancestors I will explain why I
declined that invitation also Hispanic
voters are moving to the right George
Soros has a solution for that plus
you've heard about a pandemic now the
media wants us to learn about a triple
demic is what they're calling it
protests breakout against the Communist
Regime in China and a show about
archeology is a big hit on Netflix but
the media warns that it's dangerous how
can a show about archeology be dangerous
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
huge reminder that this is the last day
of our best sale of the year it's 50 off
annual memberships and it ends at
midnight with that I have a thought to
share last week the national retail
Federation forecasted record sales for
this holiday season projecting that over
the next few weeks we will hand over to
retailers nearly one trillion dollars of
our money and what are they doing with
the money that you and I choose to give
them
well this year Walmart kicked out the my
pillow guy and used our money to force
train their workers on critical race
Theory denouncing the us as a white
supremacy system this year Amazon used
our money in their Studios division to
produce both a castrated Lord of the
Rings series which rejects masculinity
and also an anti-feminine A League of
Their Own reboot that is euphorically
unapologetically gay in quotes even this
weekend Disney used consumers money to
release an animated film called Strange
World in which a woke father encourages
a 16 year old son to flirt with another
boy these companies ridicule ideals they
they shame freedom and they warp a
child's conscience and everyone
listening or watching right now boycotts
are not enough because boycotts are
short-term they come and go in a week
and they and then these soulless
companies get back to the business of
making their morals and way of life
extinct they're only is one thing in a
global economy that can reverse the
left-hand path of multinational
corporations like Walmart and Amazon
Disney only one thing contain them and
that is competition and we are that
competition subscribers supporting the
daily wire are that competition and
because of our subscribers we will grow
into a long-term competitor to check
Disney and their kind by creating
cultural breakthroughs by releasing
explosive documentaries by uncanceling
important voices by developing
awe-inspiring films that celebrate
industry and heroism and by producing
instant children's Classics only then
only after Disney and their woke Pals
have seen the daily wire and others out
competing their content will they
reverse course or perish
so let me be as transparent as I can on
this Cyber Monday my podcast and those
of the other daily wire hosts streaming
for free on the internet do not generate
enough ad revenue for us to compete with
Disney's 30 billion dollar entertainment
budget that's what our subscribers are
for that's why we need you guys our
subscribers are concerned
citizens who choose to make long-term
investments in Daily wire plus funding
both cultural wins such as the halting
of transgender surgeries on children at
Vanderbilt and also content wins such as
daily wire's upcoming Blockbuster films
and documentaries we at the Delaware are
investing everything we've got in this
to put the government big Tech and
Hollywood back on their best behavior
and you can join us for less than a
hundred dollars right now invest long
term in the daily wire today with 50 off
new memberships and gift memberships for
your loved ones until 11 59 pm tonight
it's easier than ever to get great
content and finance our mission to help
you and your loved ones live more freely
as we head into December we're going to
start hearing more about the war on
Christmas but before the focus shifts in
that direction it's worth noticing the
much more direct and intense War being
waged on the holiday that we just
celebrated which is uh Thanksgiving the
war on Thanksgiving has been raging for
years now as the cultural powers that be
attempt to turn a time of gratitude and
celebration into an occasion for guilt
and recrimination now we know that these
forces seek to destroy all Traditions
passed To Us by our ancestors and this
is the primary issue that they have with
Christmas too uh with every holiday that
they themselves didn't invent is that
it's a tradition passed To Us by our
ancestors and so they hate it
reflexively but Thanksgiving like
Columbus Day is especially egregious in
their eyes because it Harkens back to
the European conquest of North America
which is an historical event that these
days is supposed to provoke nothing but
grief and lamentation in fact for years
the left has tried to literally Rebrand
Thanksgiving as on Thanksgiving or
as it's called in some quarters now
Thanksgiving is a national day of
mourning in recognition of course of
alleged atrocities carried out against
indigenous people by white settlers this
was the message that the left tried to
send again this past Thanksgiving many
taking the opportunity to post on social
media with messages like this this is
from journalist Walter Brahman who says
while giving thanks and celebrating the
holiday remember it is a national day of
mourning for Native Americans that marks
generations of broken promises and
oppression it is important to recognize
that Legacy as we grapple with a
resurgent fascist movement solidarity
forever and then he continues say it
with me the United States carried out a
genocide against this continent's
indigenous people and it served as a
blueprint for future Generations
a writer named Simon Moya Smith agreed
posting today is the national day of
mourning for indigenous peoples all
across uh this land we also call it on
Thanksgiving on this day we as natives
celebrate our resiliency and that we are
still here the U.S tried to kill every
indigenous man woman and child but we
are still here
and there were also acts of protests
around the country like in Chicago as
New York Post reports quote for the
second time in under two months a statue
dedicated to former President Abraham
Lincoln was defaced in Chicago on
Thanksgiving a statue of a young Abraham
Lincoln in sen Park in Chicago's
Edgewater neighborhood was found covered
in splotches of red paint along with the
words colonizer and land back
according to uh the Chicago Tribune the
statue also had Dakota 38 written on it
in reference to the Dakota Sioux members
who Link in order to be executed
following the Dakota war of 1862.
well it's a good thing that there aren't
any injustices happening in the world
today right now you know which frees us
up to frees us up to protest injustices
from 150 years ago that is quite a nice
luxury I must say
but you know maybe even something to be
thankful for I don't know just not on
Thanksgiving as the holiday is simply
too complicated now it's complicated
this indeed has become the media's
favorite term to describe Thanksgiving
with many outlets bringing in Native
American activists to talk about the
emotional complexities surrounding what
we all once thought was a simple and
wholesome holiday but it's not anymore
because it's just complicated watch
Thanksgiving of originally celebrated a
harvest Feast shared by Native Americans
and English colonists but as Fox 43's
Harry Lee explains the holiday can bring
out different emotions for indigenous
people
for many Americans Thanksgiving means
gathering with family to eat a large
meal together for Native Americans the
holiday isn't so simple a lot of people
in the Indigenous communities do want to
look at this the time in the morning
because they see you know just what we
have lost after Europeans colonize North
America many Native communities were
decimated by disease famine and
displacement Frank Little Bear of the
Plains Cree Nation explains though that
the many tribes and families of
indigenous communities now celebrate
Thanksgiving in different ways he points
out fall was always a season of thanks
it access started in October a time of
you know receiving the Harvest of like
the three sisters the corn Bean squash
deer things like that and really
preparing for winter so it was actually
a time of Celebration as for the
elementary school depictions of the
first Thanksgiving which often depict
Puritan English and Wampanoag tribe
members inaccurately dressed in Western
Plains attire I think yeah there's
there's certain things that they could
probably do better little bear says it's
still important to build a connection to
Native American culture from a young age
it's a building process that's not going
to happen overnight
build a connection to Native American
culture that's what thanksgiving's about
meanwhile the ACLU tried the repetition
technique posting on Thanksgiving
morning in all caps you are on native
land you are on native land you are on
native land you are on native land you
are on native land you are on native
land you are on native land you are on
native land
you are on native land Unfortunately
they only repeated the phrase ten times
if they could have if they could have
squeezed in that 11th time I may have
been convinced but they only got to 10.
now
uh there are a few points here that I
think are worth making first of course
the story about Thanksgiving that we
tell our children or used to tell them
is simplified
okay that's because young children are
only capable of understanding simple
Concepts you give them the simple
version first and then over time you
build on it adding layers of complexity
and in fact the left agrees with this
which is why they haven't actually set
out to give children a more complex or
nuanced understanding of the European
settlement of the new world instead
they've replaced one simplified story
with a different
but even more simplified story it's just
been simplified in the other direction
so the popular and simplified myth now
told not just the children but hammered
into everybody's head
is a story of evil barbaric white people
who came here and just immediately
carried out a genocide against peaceful
Indians who never did a single thing to
deserve or provoke any of the violence
visited upon them
this is the story we're supposed to
believe now it is the new founding myth
of America
you know every nation has its founding
myth right usually the myths are
designed to instill pride and patriotism
and gratitude
and yes they're not always 100 accurate
but people in other cultures and in
other countries they don't spend time
debunking well that's not exactly how it
happened they wouldn't have been dressed
like that
that's not the point of the story okay
to getting the Wardrobe details right
isn't the point
a lot of times the point is again to
instill Pride patriotism and gratitude
but our new founding myth is designed
instead to instill resentment and guilt
and shame
the modern Western world is the only
civilization in history that I'm aware
of
that lies to itself about its own
history and founding in order to make
itself seem worse
second as I've pointed out many times in
the past and we'll continue to point out
the claim that we stole land from Native
Americans from some group called quote
Native Americans or quote indigenous
people is incoherent there never was any
homogeneous group of natives occupying
this land before the settlers got here
okay it's not like the whole country was
was uh was uh occupied by this one group
that we would call Native Americans
there were rather disparate and warring
tribes that waged Wars of conquest and
extermination against each other and had
been doing so for centuries before we
arrived the ACLU says that we're on
native land but whose land exactly I
mean which natives
the ones who were most recently
occupying the land when white people
showed up or the ones who those natives
stole it from
or the natives who the natives it was
stolen from stolen from or the natives
who had it before that Etc
I mean you have to be more specific
but you can't be more specific because
there is no coherent chain of custody
for this allegedly stolen Land There was
for thousands of years rather only the
law of Conquest which is a law that all
people lived by and died by
that doesn't make it right doesn't make
it wrong it just makes it what it is
what it was it simply means that it
doesn't make any sense to try and
identify special victims of Conquest
because every conquered people were
conquerors before they were conquered
so
there are winners and losers in such a
system this is a distinction you want to
talk about they left once Nuance well
here it is
in a world governed by the law of
Conquest which is how the whole world
was governed for thousands of years
there are winners and losers
but it is much harder to identify
villains and victims
you know by the law of the land at the
time it's hard to make villains out of
Indian tribes that for example massacred
settlements
that's just how it worked and they were
on the settlements were on land that
those Indian tribes wanted or felt that
they had a right to
but it's also hard to make villains out
of the settlers who responded in kind to
that sort of aggression again it's the
way the world worked
we can only be grateful that we do not
live in times nearly as harsh or
unforgiving as that
and we can and should be grateful to our
ancestors who gave us
the comfortable and luxurious lives that
we lead
modern people love to Feast at the
banquet of Western Civilization while
still whining about the people who
provided the banquet
and judging them for doing what they had
to do in order to provide it
but you notice that none of these people
are leaving the banquet they're still
shoving their fat ungrateful faces
third and and this is the point that I
most wanted to drive home
and it is this
I am
a Native American okay I am a Native
American
and so are most of you in the audience
and I don't mean that in the Elizabeth
Warren sense I'm not claiming one one
thousandth Comanche blood or whatever
I'm saying that I was born here I am a
citizen
and therefore I am a native I am a
native to this country and I am an
American therefore I am a Native
American
now that's a title that we really need
to start using correctly
any any legal citizen born in this
country is native to it and thus is a
Native American
we have no trouble recognizing this when
it comes to State citizenship now if I
told you that I was a native marylander
because I was born in Maryland nobody
would have any problem with that I am
native to Maryland because I was born
there
and yet somehow we have this idea that I
can be native to Maryland again
something no one would dispute
a native marylander and yet not native
to the country that Maryland is a part
of so I can say I'm a native marylander
but I cannot say I'm a Native American
because that title native to the country
is reserved for a very specific group of
people uh to a special victim group
because they were here originally we're
told
but they weren't
because if you trace it back far enough
every person who has ever lived on this
side of the world is originally from the
other side of it
nobody is native here in the absolute
sense
we are all descended from foreign Nomads
all of us
and yet my ancestors came here
just as the ancestors of those we call
indigenous came here
and my ancestors fought for this land
and conquered it just as the so-called
indigenous people had done before them
and then I was born
and this is my country it is my home
it is my native land
and I'm proud of that
and I apologize to no one for it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know on Friday we released the first
two episodes of the brand new biblical
series by Dr Jordan B Peterson this
series is called Exodus and in it Jordan
Peterson sits down with other Scholars
to read the book of Exodus and discuss
what it means and why it remains
significant thousands of years after it
was written Scholars at the table
include Dennis Prager Jonathan Pago and
uh and many more as well there will be
new episodes releasing weekly and trust
me you don't want to miss this series so
check out the trailer here it is
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny I want villains to get punished
but do you want the villains to learn
before they have to pay the ultimate
price that's such a Christian question
you got to be a member to watch the head
of dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member and watch Exodus today
all right I want to begin with a story
that um
is not one of the headlines that grabbed
everybody's attention over the weekend
in fact this story has grabbed
comparatively few people's attention but
it's important enough that I'm I'm uh
I'm gonna mention it here so this is the
story from Fox it says a liberal group
linked to billionaire George Soros has
been cleared by the FCC to purchase
Spanish language radio stations
throughout the country rekindling
concerns that a radical political agenda
will influence information provided to
Hispanic voters
Miami's iconic Spanish language
conservative talk radio station radio
Mambi is one of the 18 stations the
Soros back Latino Media Group will
purchase from Televisa Univision for a
reported 60 million dollars radio mondi
which is historically linked to the
Cuban Exile community and offers an
anti-communism view will be controlled
by liberals once the deal is finalized
Latino media Network which is partially
financed by an investment group
affiliated with Soros the Soros fund
management
is controlled by Jess Morales a former
Hillary for America and AFL-CIO employee
and former Obama White House staffer as
well the FCC rejected a petition to
block the proposed sale
and uh so that's the news
so why is this important well
I think that should be obvious George
Soros who is
truly one of the worst human beings to
ever live on the planet at least in the
past I don't know two centuries I put
them in the top five top ten at least
and he is his he has moved from
financing the destruction of our cities
with woke DA's who don't enforce the law
to now buying Spanish language radio
stations and flipping them over to make
them leftists I mean he's still buying
up the DA's as well it's not like he has
to choose between the two that's the
advantage of being a billionaire but uh
he's doing both and a lot more as well
um the idea here is to counter the move
to the right that we're seeing in the
Hispanic community
because the left for so long has taken
the Hispanic vote for granted uh that's
why they've in large part why they've
opened up the borders to begin with
shift as many
um uh Hispanic people here here as they
can that's what the great replacement is
all about
the great replacement that you know
Chuck Schumer admitted to a week ago but
they've hit a snack because they've
found that Latinos are voting Republican
more and more with each election
now the Democrats still get the majority
of the Latino vote but but it's it's
trending in the wrong direction for them
because they lost a portion of their
usual share in the 2018 midterms
um then even more in the 2020 election
and then even more in the 2022 midterms
uh again things are trending in the
wrong direction so what do they do about
it well you cue George Soros
there's a literal comic book villain he
even looks like the bad guy in a cartoon
or something and his plan is to buy the
votes back
by taking over the information Pipelines
that's what's happening
and as I've as I've established now he
in case it wasn't clear he is an evil
son of a [ __ ] I mean the world would be
a better place when he dies and I know
we're not supposed to say that sort of
thing well no no the left can say that
but on the right you're not allowed to
ever point that out or say that but it's
just it's just a fact I mean the guy's
like 92 years old he's done immense
damage to the to the world and when he
is no longer in the world it will be it
would be better for everyone
and all of that is true
but at the same time uh we can also
recognize I think that this is the left
playing chess
while we on the right play checkers
right which is a a
common problem
they go on offense always
so they notice that they're losing the
Spanish vote so instead of just like
whining about it on Twitter they go out
and do this they try to reclaim the
information Pipelines
they go to war for it
human beings have been going to war for
resources since time and immemorial well
now the greatest resource is is not
something you can dig out of the ground
it's information
and as a political resource it's it's I
mean it's the number one political
resource
and the left is at War to control it
that's why they're so upset about Elon
Musk taking over Twitter they see it as
a significant defeat
in this battle right for to control the
information which it is
and this move by Soros it's not going to
be enough to neutralize the effect of
what Elon Musk has done but uh it's a
start anyway and that's what they're
doing
and we need to get our heads in the game
and realize that
all right so you've heard about a
pandemic
well now say hello to a triple demick
this is from uh Mother Jones says
respiratory illnesses are sweeping the
nation overwhelming hospitals causing
kids to miss school and keeping adults
home from work the culprit covid and
respiratory uh well RSV is the virus and
the flu so that's all three of them Dr
William Schaffner says we're facing an
onslaught of three viruses covet RSV and
influential all simultaneously we're
calling this a triple democ is what is
is the word they're using also I've also
heard triedemic used I think I prefer
triedemic of the two
um and it's not a term made up by Mother
Jones this is what the media is running
with and here's the thing
they are right that RSV is a scary virus
in children that's for sure we've had
more than one child who ended up in the
emergency room with RSV I've had to sit
by the hospital bed more than once with
a young child who's struggling to
breathe it is one of the scariest things
you can experience as a parent as far as
the flu goes again yes that can be
extremely serious with kids
as I mentioned we have we've had the flu
go through our house this month
um and it's uh you know all the kids had
nasty coughs for two weeks my wife is
pregnant with twins still hasn't
completely gotten over it but the point
is that RSV and the flu have always been
with us
or at least they've they've been known
about for decades I think RSV was first
identified 70 or 80 years ago or so
so and and they've always been the far
greater concern especially for kids
there was never any reason for parents
to worry about covet with their kids
there's never any good reason for that
there's never any good data backed
reason for parents to be overly worried
or even worried at all actually about
coveting their kids
um but flu and RSV were always the real
risks
and that's what some of us many of us
have been saying for years now
but we were shut down castigated ignored
silenced
and now we're getting all these panicky
stories about flu and RSV
um also including covid like they throw
covet into it just so that Kobe doesn't
get its feelings hurt I guess but we're
getting these stories as though the
media
just found out that these viruses exist
even though they've always existed
and and we continue to live our lives in
spite of them
right they're they're out there we know
that
but we live our lives because what else
what the hell else are we supposed to do
you take basic precautions you wash your
hands that kind of thing if you're sick
if your child is sick you stay home
that's that's most people have always
understood that you do that we don't
need the CDC to tell us we don't need
any kind of official quarantine
recommendation is it five days is it ten
days is it two weeks
it's always been pretty obvious if your
kids up clearly sick has a fever it's
coughing and all that then you stay home
if you can
but other than that you basically just
live your life what other option is
there
that's that's what we've been saying all
along
like if we were not covered in RSV
especially again when it comes to kids
they've always been out there we've
always known about them
uh and yet we we continue to live our
lives
why then would we respond differently to
coven that's the thing they could never
explain
uh on CNN they're dealing with this
triedemic and the senior medical
correspondent has some advice on on how
we can deal with this let's listen to
that
I know a lot of this has to do with the
fact that people were taking such big
mitigation steps over the last several
years that's why we're seeing such a
difference now a big question people
want to know though is how they avoid
getting sick as the flu cases are
already this high and people are
gathering for the holidays they're out
and about much more than they have been
in the last several years
right Caitlin so all of the advice that
I'm going to give you you have heard it
before there is nothing new Under The
Sun It's very basic stuff it's things
like getting a flu shot so important
washing your hands frequently and if you
want to no one's advising you to but if
you want to certainly wearing a mask is
going to help protect you against the
flu not to mention things like RSV and
covet and other respiratory diseases as
you mentioned flu hospitalizations at a
high right now for this point in the
season such an early flu season if you
look all the way to the right you can
see a bar that represents the rate now
all the rates over the past 10 years way
lower at this point in the season
if you want to if you want to you can
you can wear a mask she says and no
one's advising it at this point but uh
but if you want to you can at least for
right now they're not advising
this this was always where this was
going to head is that uh
you know once once people stop worrying
about covid and you're not able to this
this is why they've moved on from covet
largely in the media uh it's got nothing
to do with with the numbers or anything
like that
it's just because they couldn't they
couldn't get the fear reaction out of
people they just uh it it most people
the the fear Panic the panic button was
had been pressed too much and it was
just spent and they couldn't get that
reaction anymore out of people and so
but they still want to keep us muzzled
so maybe you move on and say well yeah
where where the where the mask now for
the flu
even though again
no one ever suggested that prior to
covet medic masks existed medical masks
existed respiratory illnesses existed
and yet there was no push by anyone
to tell people to wear masks
until Kobe came along
all right Tony fauci uh officially
retired yet that hasn't stopped him from
doing the news circuit he interviewed on
Face the Nation over the weekend where
among other things he talked about the
anti-china approach as he puts it that
the Trump administration had to the
covet virus fauci still has not forgiven
Trump for being mean to China when China
Unleashed a virus on the entire globe
and that's that's the thing that's most
upsetting to him so here he is talking
about that
what happens is that if you look at the
anti-china approach that clearly the
Trump administration had right from the
very beginning and the accusatory nature
the Chinese are going to Flinch back and
say no sorry we're not going to talk to
you about it which is not correct but
they're not talking to the Biden
Administration about it either exactly I
think that horse is out of the bond and
they're very suspicious of anybody
trying to accuse them we need to have an
open dialogue with their scientists and
our scientists keep the politics out of
it and let the scientists because these
are scientists that we've known for
decades
yes we wouldn't want to accuse China we
shouldn't accuse them they simply just
created the virus uh they created covet
in their Wuhan lab uh created and
Unleashed it on the world
but and that's that's the only question
that still exists here is is how exactly
it ended up getting Unleashed in the
world and to what extent was it
intentional that's the only question
that maybe still
is still a Live question but it will
never be answered because the people
that would be in charge of answering
that question I have no interest
so they created the virus Unleashed on
the world one way or another but let's
not point fingers I mean this is a this
is a courtesy that fauci would extend to
anyone I'm sure if you walked up to him
on the street and punched him in his
lying little Elvish face I'm sure he
would say well let's not let's not
point fingers let's not accuse
yes this person punched me directly in
the face and is 100 to blame for doing
so but uh but can we blame them for that
even so
meanwhile there are speaking of China
the daily wire has this report Chinese
citizens are protesting the Communist
nation's strict coveted policies with at
least one demonstration turning violent
protests intense fight over the weekend
in major cities across China including
Beijing Shanghai and Wuhan according to
Media reports a demonstration in
Shanghai eventually devolved into chaos
with police clashman protesters and
deploying pepper spray the protests
emerged as a response to the zero covid
policies imposed by the Chinese
Communist Party government since the
beginning of the pandemic
and now we're seeing
apparently
and you always have to say apparently
because you can never be you never be
sure with anything that we that comes
out of China any information that we get
out of China uh but apparently we're
seeing these widespread protests
which by the way
if you want to
protest oppression or anything like that
this this is what takes actual courage
to be a BLM writer in the United States
there's no courage there
but to protest as a Chinese citizen to
protest the Chinese government
that takes courage more courage than the
White House has by the way because the
White House put out this statement I
listen to the statement from the White
House about the um
the what's happening in China
this is their statement
we've said that zero covid is not a
policy that we are pursuing here in the
United States and as we've said we think
it's going to be very difficult for the
People's Republic of China to be able to
contain this virus through their zero
coveted strategy for us we are focused
on what works and that means using the
public health tools like continuing to
enhance vaccination rates including
boosters and making testing and
treatment easily available accessible
we've long said everyone has the right
to peacefully protest here in the United
States and around the world this
includes in the PRC it will be hard to
come up with
a weaker or more pathetic statement than
that
these are
protests against communist tyranny
being violently put down and we'll never
know the ex even the extent of that
because again this is coming from China
and talk about controlling the the
pipelines of information the Chinese
communist government has almost complete
control over it
so we'll never even know the full extent
of it
but they're violently putting down these
protests and the White House's response
is not even criticizing that it's not
criticizing that it's just it's just
criticizing the efficacy of of zero
coveted policies
even though they all supported those
kinds of policies themselves for two
years
great
all right you know the story about the
shooting at the gay club in Colorado
Springs has uh you may have noticed this
has already disappeared
which is interesting
as soon as the shooters
non-quote-unquote non-binary
self-identity was revealed the story
just evaporated like floated away in a
puff of smoke
at least that's what the media would
prefer that's that's the vanishing
Houdini act that the media is trying to
pull off but uh we should not let them
do that okay I could say that I'm not
I'm not done with the story
which is why I want to play this clip
from CNN last week and this is a clip of
a of a man who identifies as a woman a
quote unquote trans woman who is a
friend of one of the victims and I want
you to hear how he deals with the fact
that
the shooter was is identifies as
non-binary this is pretty amazing listen
to this
Natalie when we started the show we just
got we got a little bit of news earlier
that the attorneys for the shooter
um are now saying that the shooter is
non-binary and the shoe this shooter
would like to use the pronouns they them
and this is for the court in all court
papers and that's what
um Anderson Al aldrich's attorneys are
saying do you have any thoughts on that
yeah I think that's
um complete ludicrous
[Applause]
um I believe they're just saying that
because they want to have
um
the easy way out on this
um that's it really really
um offending especially being a
transgender woman myself that a male
which it was obvious with the mug shot
that's a man that's not a non-binary
person because in no way shape or form
could they appear as a woman the next
day it's really offensive to even hear
that that they're playing that role
um and if they're non-binary why would
you go after the club where you feel
safe at
why would you do that to a community
where you are welcomed in if you are
non-binary
excellent question obviously all of this
will have to be answered
wow
Okay so
uh this person has made the Judgment
call that the shooter is not really
non-binary because he doesn't because he
looks like a male and uh and so so so he
the person on CNN is making a a judgment
about this other person's self-identity
by physically assessing them
this is just and and this is why the
story went away
um
I mean for the obvious reason right that
it's not it's the the media completely
embarrassed itself
uh it's uh you know try to use this
event to defame people like myself and
live to take Dr Carlson and it all blew
up in their faces and now that the
person has been revealed as a as a you
know someone who identifies as
non-binary it's not useful to them
um and so that's why they're they're
trying to put this aside and by the way
it's been a week now since this happened
uh and this the the claim that we got
from the media
right after the non-binary wrinkle came
to light was that well this they're just
claiming this now and and uh clearly
this is still a right-wing militant
person who's just claiming non-binary
status to troll or to get out of the
hate crime charge which as I explained
last week doesn't make any sense to
begin with
but
we know that that isn't true what the
media is saying to try to you know
dismiss this
because if there was any evidence like a
week later if there was any evidence
that this person was actually a right
winger who was motivated because of
things that Tucker Carlson said
or who they like followed me on Twitter
or something if that was true if there
was even a shred of evidence of any of
that we wouldn't know it by now it's
been a week
you notice how as far as I know we
haven't even been told we haven't we
haven't even been told what the shooter
himself is saying he was captured alive
after all
we've been told none of that or very
little of it
um
as I said last week if if a mass
shooting happens and it's actually a
right-wing person to commit a mass
shooting we will know everything about
that person in like two hours we'll have
every detail of their life in two hours
and if if it goes beyond two hours three
four five hours and we've heard almost
nothing and then it's two days and we've
heard almost nothing well that tells you
that uh whatever this person's you know
whatever the the details of this
person's life
it doesn't work for the media narrative
we know that
but the other reason that they had to uh
just move move on from this story
is that I think they realized
they were completely
exploding their own gender ideology
talking points
everything that we've heard from CNN
that really is going back to that video
clip for a minute that just is an
amazing video
I mean how how many times have we of
course been told that you can't even
when when a baby is born
uh you can't even declare their sex male
or female
you can't declare it based on
you know Anatomy you can't declare based
on DNA your chromosomes
even if you have access to all that
information
and yet
this person could look at a mug shot of
a of the shooter and just based on that
alone say oh yeah not even not even that
he's not a woman that he's not
non-binary
whatever that even means to begin with
all right I also wanted to to mention
this so Cat 10 barge is the uh speaking
of groomers Cat 10 bars is the tech and
culture reporter for NBC News
and she tweeted this I guess this was on
Thanksgiving this is what she was
thinking about on Thanksgiving I was
with my family but she was tweeting this
uh she said Tucker Carlson lives of tick
tock Etc create a stream of content
blaming trans and queer people for child
grooming but rarely or never feature
actual victims of child grooming if they
did
that have to reckon with the fact that
many survivors are queer and trans
themselves
huh
that's interesting cat
so if they if we reckoned with action
with the actual grooming of children
then we would we would realize that many
of the survivors of grooming are queer
and trans themselves
do you understand what you've just
admitted to
by the way I don't disagree with
anything she said there
um
aside from the you know the the
accusations she's making against Tucker
Carlson who lives of tick tock aside
from that but the gist of her point I
agree with
I totally agree with it in fact this is
like the Unspeakable you're not allowed
to even say this out loud even though
it's true
um
you know to to identify the potential
link between child abuse and then kids
who identify as some version of LGBT
this is a this is a this is a a link you
can see if you look at the at the data
points
but you're not allowed to point out but
cat just did
because she doesn't realize what she
just said
yes why are cat ask yourself this
why is it that so many of the quote
survivors of grooming are queer and
trans
might that indicate
that the queer and trans identities
among children
are a product of The Grooming
so you've got all the dots you see all
the dots now now just connect them is
all you got to do
and then you'll see the full picture
uh one other thing before we get to the
comment section
because I could not neglect to gloat
about this
now you may you may recall from my
appearance on Dr Phil and I mean I've
made this point many times
uh or I've talked about hey if we're if
we're
allowing people to have preferred
pronouns and we're respecting their
preferred pronouns then what about other
grammatical constructs I mean what about
what about a preferred adjective for
example
as you know my preferred adjective is
handsome and brilliant
and I said that partly as a joke on Dr
Phil I don't know six months ago fast
forward six months and we have this on
Tick Tock listen
I just had a parent ask me my preferred
adjectives
because she wanted to comment on one of
my photos but she wanted to use words
that I liked hearing
for myself
that's the kind of allyship that I need
a plus
and this is why parity is impossible
I got a lot of respect for the Babylon
bee because they they have to stay ahead
of the curve on this it's very difficult
to do and things move so quickly that
something moves from parity to reality
in like the blink of an eye and there it
is
now now we are actually talking about
preferred adjectives
because why not it actually makes a lot
of sense
if if I am required to affirm yourself
perception
then why would that not extend to
you know adjectives as well I mean like
however I describe my I I see myself a
certain way and if you are required to
affirm however I see myself then why
would we not extend that
to to adjectives as well and that's
where we are
let's get to the comment section
name
there's a sweet baby game
old-schooled says imagine the Meltdown
if there was a purity and abstinence
Story Hour at local libraries
well old school that is a I would
if I were to put to make a hall of fame
for comments in the comments section
yours would yours would be in it because
that is a very very good point very good
and simple point that I wish I had
thought to make myself
um
yeah uh imagine that imagine if it was
like a rather than having
um
a drag queen a man dressed up as a woman
come and read to the kids yes what if it
was a a purity and abstinence a purity
and modesty you know Story Hour
where it's all it's very modestly
dressed individual man or a woman
reading books about modesty
I think you've made the point
um The Way of the hero says I wouldn't
want a stripper to read books to kids
just as much as I wouldn't want a drag
queen to do such this isn't specifically
about drag queens this is about keeping
the barrier intact
between children and adult sexuality
uh right exactly this is this is why as
I've always said I mean and I think the
right way you say stripper
I mean and you look at some of the
footage of these drag events
family-friendly drag events it is
basically you know it is not even
basically like there is actual stripping
going on
but um
I think more often it's better compared
to burlesque and we wouldn't want
kids be exposed to that the only problem
with this argument is I think more and
more the left is going to say and
they're saying now that look well why
not sure let's let's have let's bring
kids to the strip club too
why why not I mean it's just it's just
sexuality it's not scary
and if you objected you say no don't
bring kids to the strip club you freaks
they'll say well what are you afraid of
strippers for
so I think I think that's going to be
the response is that they're sort of
like gonna take us up on that
um
all right Matthew Grove Jones says
I don't think Matt's that much older
than me but I look to him as a father
figure I think that's the whole meaning
of the sweet baby gang not sure only
been into walshe for a few years now
I may have missed something
well
if you've been listening for a few years
then you should know
not to commit to sins that you've
committed here Matthew
one is to speculate about the origins of
the sweet baby gang which you should
know we do not do and the other is to
call me woolshi
so you if it's possible you are banned
from you're banned from the show
readmitted and then banned again
for both of those offenses
um
Sabri says cute to see how Matt lives
under the impression that his SBG does
not enjoy seeing him suffer and
therefore will help him out of his anime
deal looking forward to seeing you watch
anime soon Matt well I am greatly
disappointed that well I'll read some of
these other comments but I'm I was
looking over I I did say
please recommend to me uh an anime
that's got two or three minute episodes
and like three or four episodes in a
season and if that doesn't exist because
I'm not going to blame the SPG for the
fact that that doesn't exist if it
doesn't but if it but if it doesn't
exist then I need someone to make that
anime is that so much to ask and put it
up on YouTube and then I can watch that
and fulfill the terms of my deal but no
one has done that I checked
you had the whole Thanksgiving break to
make an anime and put it on YouTube to
help me out here
deeply disappointed
draconic Fang says I recommend Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood there are 64
episodes around 18 minutes per very well
done and has some strong heart clenching
moments
64 episodes
at 18 minutes an episode do the math on
that I can't off the top of my head it's
that's a lot of minutes I know that much
you are not understanding the assignment
here 64 episodes I have to live stream
this don't you understand that's what
like I have to watch the whole thing on
a live stream
um are there any better uh
recommendations Daniel says Matt
watching anime this will be good I hope
they choose the weebiest ones
the one people seem to walk in at the
most awkward moments for God be with you
Matt I don't even know the weebiest
I don't know what that means exactly but
I don't want a wee be one okay that
doesn't sound good
um
JG says Walsh is a genius he took a
sarcastic statement about anime and said
it to stir up controversy which sells
flipped it to sell an extra 100 books
and is going to monetize watching anime
since reaction videos are huge I'm sure
he's going to make a pretty penny off of
this Bravo Matt I wish I could tell you
that this is also a master plan on my
part I appreciate that that assumption
um but uh I I appreciate your your faith
this is all a 4D chess move but it's
really not and if it was again I would
not I would have flipped it for not 100
books but a thousand ten thousand
people are so desperate to see me suffer
through anime that I could have demanded
10 000 books and I think it would have
happened
um
Vigilant the wolf says the most demonic
anime of all is Hetalia but the episodes
are only five minutes long if you last
through a season I'll be extremely
impressed
well there's an interesting moral
quandary so you're saying so this is a
short one yet it's the most demonic
so we know that all anime is demonic and
causes demonic possession but you're
saying this is the most demonic but it's
also very short
so do I want to do that or do I want to
do a longer anime that's a little bit
less demonic I guess that's what we have
to figure out
and I need your help let's do that again
I still am imploring for your help
let's get to the Daily cancellation
[Music]
if the price of your Thanksgiving meal
has left a bad taste in your mouth
remember it's completely normal to keep
paying more and more for the same things
right wrong well right now the daily
wire plus cyber week sale is on and
everything in our shop is 40 off that's
right 40 off my Johnny the Wahlberg's
book Johnny The Walrus plushie or you
can get the bundles 40 off for that as
well 40 off the leftist tears dog bowl
the iconic daily wire truth bomb and
don't forget it's free shipping on
orders over 75 and you get a free left
to Sears tumbler with orders over a
hundred dollars so unless you're one of
the super fans who actually wants to
give us extra money don't wait go to
dailywire.com shop today and get our
best deals of the year on all the gifts
worth giving
this weekend I watched one of the
biggest hits on Netflix right now which
is a documentary series from a
journalist named Graham Hancock the show
is called ancient apocalypse and in the
series just as he has throughout his
career Hancock argues that there was a
lost Global civilization that existed on
Earth some 12 000 years ago but it was
wiped out in a cataclysm
that erased most traces of this
civilization he claims that our
ancestors had a memory of this cataclysm
the the ancient Apocalypse in the title
which they recounted in the biblical
story of the flood and in other ancient
texts around the world
the way he puts it you know he says that
we are a a species with amnesia we don't
know the story of our own past and we
accept what we've been told by
mainstream science and Academia which
insists that there were was no you know
there were no civilizations at all in
fact certainly not Advanced ones prior
to about 4000 BC that's the mainstream
accepted version of events
um Hancock says that they're ignoring or
even potentially covering up evidence to
the contract
and what is the evidence well
much of it centers around various
ancient structures around the world that
have turned out to be much older than
they originally thought to be Hancock
points to for example
um one thousand-year-old pyramids that
as it turns out were built over top even
older pyramids which were built over
older ones like the kind of Russian
nesting doll sort of situation the
evidence indicates that that our
ancestors were in fact building bigger
and more complicated things earlier than
previously assumed
and so Hancock is is pointing to some of
this also there's the similarity between
these ancient structures like the
Egyptians weren't the only ones who
built pyramids obviously ancient people
all over the world made their own
versions of pyramids and they were
usually built to correspond with
astronomical phenomena
why did all these societies separated by
oceans and millennia
decide to build these structures and how
did they build them
that's an interesting question and one
that has never been sufficiently
answered Graham Hancock's answer is that
the survivors of a lost Ice Age
civilization went around the world
passing down the knowledge of how to
build these pyramids along with teaching
Agriculture and architecture and art Etc
um
and that's how they figured out how to
do it now why did these survivors do
this and how did they survive the
apocalypse that wiped out their
civilization and where were they
stationed for the centuries that would
have taken them to go around the whole
world teaching these techniques to
thousands of different societies and how
were they able to communicate with all
these people speaking different
languages and why isn't there any actual
material evidence of this Advanced
civilization that supposedly existed 12
000 years ago
Hancock says that it was wiped out in a
cataclysm but he also says that there
were enough survivors to support this
Global campaign to civilize the entire
world which means that there were a lot
of survivors
uh why didn't they leave behind any
direct evidence of their existence
these questions and many more are not
answered by Graham Hancock
which is why
I don't personally buy much of what he's
selling I am not persuaded
and yet
I very much enjoyed the series just as
I've enjoyed listening to him explain
his ideas during his several appearances
on Joe Rogan's podcast I've read one of
his books I found it interesting
um I think his theory is
are quite interesting and entertaining
and also outlandish and probably dead
wrong
despite what you've been told it is
possible to have this opinion about
someone or something it is possible to
believe that someone is wrong
and yet still find them fascinating
it is possible to disagree with
someone's ideas
and yet still believe that the ideas are
worth listening to
say whatever else you want about Graham
Hancock he is to use the cliche in
outside the box thinker and I can
personally always appreciate those types
of people we need more of those people
in the world not fewer they make life
more interesting they make conversations
more interesting
and they get people talking about
subjects that they would otherwise
ignore I mean a show about ancient
archeology is now the biggest hit on
Netflix
which I think as someone who enjoys
history that's that's worth celebrating
in its own right even if you reject his
hypothesis completely
this is not a difficult needle to thread
okay it's not hard to say
I disagree with your ideas
but I'm glad you've shared them
at least it shouldn't be hard
yet it's somehow beyond the capacity of
the mainstream media which has one word
for ideas that fall outside of the
mainstream well they have a few words
but one of the most uh the most common
words is it's the word is not
interesting but rather dangerous
it's dangerous if it falls outside of
the mainstream hence many headlines
published over the past few days like
this one from the guardian says ancient
apocalypse is the most dangerous Show on
Netflix
and then the subheader of that article
says this
a show with a truly Preposterous theory
is one of the streaming Giants biggest
hits and it seems to exist solely for
conspiracy theorists
why has this been allowed
wait why has it been allowed
who is supposed to disallow it
well the writer never explains that he
also never really explains what exactly
makes a Preposterous quote-unquote
theory about ancient prehistory
dangerous
what is the danger precisely
so a bunch of people come to believe
that an advanced civilization existed
during the last ice age and and then
what what catastrophe is supposed to
follow from that
other articles have taken it a step
further claiming that the show is not
only dangerous but racist as well a
headline from a different publication
declares that there is a whole bunch of
quote white supremacist nonsense behind
Netflix's ancient apocalypse
yet Hancock never says anything about
race in the show or in his books as far
as I know
even if you think that his Lost
Civilization theory is the dumbest thing
you've ever heard in your life what in
the world makes it racist
well that's never explained either but
it doesn't have to be we already know
that this is the media's version of
Tourette's they just reflexively blurred
out the word racist when faced with
anything they don't like everything they
personally disapprove of is racist and
dangerous
as for the latter charge the best
attempt at an explanation comes from the
guardian article I mentioned which
arrives at this conclusion at the end it
says that's the danger of a show like
this it Whispers to the conspiracy
theorists in all of us and Hancock is
such a compelling host that he's bound
to create a few more in his wake
believing that Ultra intelligent
creatures help to build the pyramids is
one thing but where does it end
believing that election fraud is real
believing 9 11 was an inside job worse
if you were feeling particularly
mean-spirited you could suggest that
Netflix knows this and has gone out of
its way to court the conspiracy
theorists
ah so there it is if you question the
narrative from mainstream archaeologists
the fear is that it might send you
tumbling down a rabbit hole where you
begin to think critically and
skeptically about a whole host of other
topics as well
like election integrity
this is indeed a dangerous possibility
dangerous anyway to the people in charge
of formulating and disseminating the
official narrative
I mean this is really the sin that
Graham Graham Hancock has committed he's
pointing out holes in the official story
he's encouraging skepticism
now the theories that he formulates may
have many holes of their own I think
they do but that's not the issue as far
as the narrative Gatekeepers are
concerned I mean they don't care if
something is wrong they themselves are
wrong all the time wrongness is not a
problem for them
the problem is when people notice how
little they The Gatekeepers actually
know
how how fragile and tentative their own
theories are
how unearned and unjustified is their
confidence
that's what makes a documentary series
about ancient archeology dangerous
is that it might make you a little
skeptical of The Gatekeepers
which I guess is dangerous yeah but it's
the right kind of dangerous
and that is why it's not Graham Hancock
who's canceled today but The Gatekeepers
trying to shame and silence him they are
all canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]